it's so wonderful to see both of you i
just finished a series last night i'm
trying to get it all in my head it is
probably the best
season of all and uh congratulations to
the both of you i mean to see johnny do
wax on wax i'm doing it wrong and i wax
on wax off i'm a drink right i don't
know uh is epic so what does it mean to
see that people are so obsessed with
this show
yeah
it's uh it's crazy it's a lot of fun uh
learning wax on wax off and and then
having the miyagi dough coming to johnny
versus and the eagle fan going to the
miyagi dough it's a really fun blend
that adds for you know a lot of fun
comedy and drama attention and
all that's so fun to play and it's great
that the fans have just embraced the
show we're you know it's a big family
it's like a party and we're happy that
it's been it's received the response it
has and i'm
excited moving forward
you know there's a viral video right now
of you doing the crane kick in front of
ralph and uh you know i mean
what was that moment like for you guys
that has been so much fun well you can
see how that crane kick lands
it was like yeah it was great it was it
was fun i mean it's you know we get to
it's like such this gift that keeps on
giving we get to take all these pieces
that were
birthed back in 1983 or 84 when the
movie came out and and to bring it
forward and open up and come from a
different prisoner perspective uh it's
just it's it's so rewarding and this
season you know it's it starts off it's
so nice to have
after sort of the epic darkness of the
end of season three
to have the humor with daniel and johnny
and just these these two guys
trying to work together uh uh
you know get
tripping over their own personalities to
to attempt to do what they believe is
right for the kids is really a pleasure
to to play and and it really um you know
builds towards the ultimate climax as
you just saw which is really just um all
in everything and the kids are just so
incredible in it as well they're so good
they're growing up too and
talking about the obsession andrew
garfield said how much he loved the show
and you guys made a video for him did
you see his reaction to it yes we did
yeah
it was uh that was all and everything as
i just alluded to it really was
earnest and beautiful and uh that's
that's the that was just epic cross
promotion
concept that netflix put together and it
was uh it was a win-win for everybody he
needs to be part of season five i think
he needs to show up maybe as your
brother i don't know something
the door is wide open we love it we love
them
uh you know what's so great about the
show is too the fact that it talks about
issues that kids go through uh you know
even with this season starts out with a
kid who's dealing with bullying how
important is it for you that these these
story lines are part of the show and
have you ever dealt with bullying
yourselves
it's been something um i mean
that's ingrained in the karate kid
universe um and it's really
um credit john josh and hayden uh the
first word out of their mouths when they
pitched me this concept was bullying um
so from the onset that was always part
of the through line one of the through
lines that they wanted to bring forth to
the next generation and i think
um
with the new carry the new kenny
character in season four um it explores
that and never let's let's go of it
because it's something we all deal with
it whether it's and it's more
complicated now with with technology and
everything else and whether it's in the
workplace or in the schoolyard um so
i uh for myself i had you know not a
great deal of problems with bullying but
i did have episodes and certainly in
middle school
you know being
at that time the skinniest and the
youngest looking and i was you know an
easy target but i made friends with the
some of the cool guys really early and
got to tap dance myself at her
that regard go ahead william um yeah
bill you know i think every bully was
once a victim and that's kind of saying
you know it's like yeah you know so yeah
everybody you know that's what i think
the show explores and you see kenny uh
you know this character and uh this new
character which is great and also for
the show to keep keep introducing
reintroducing new kids into the blood
into the of the show keeps we have to
have more kids coming through the
training and see where they're coming
from and all that serves the show
amazingly and it's obviously a huge
theme i mean at the beginning of season
one johnny's protecting uh this kid in
the parking lot and he's pulling a
little miyagi out and um
you know and uh so again and it's it's a
big it's a big theme and i think martial
arts really gives you a handle on that i
know there's a lot of good like
brazilian jiu-jitsu has a great
anti-bully type of approach and you know
you learn karate not to fight those
types of things um yeah i mean i you
know i think we ought scraps as kids i
was a new kid funny enough i moved from
california to new york uh new york to
california when i was 10
and you know one of my first days of
school i had a group of kids come and
you know
come at me you know and you know you
deal with it and
um you know and uh and then me make
friends with them and then the next
thing you're part of their gang and
you're having ice cream playing handball
so you know um but it's a sad thing it's
you know bullying is a real thing it's
very serious thing um and not just
physically but in every other way
emotionally mentally and all that and
the definition of a bully as i
understand it is somebody that makes you
feel less than who you are and smaller
than yourself and um you know so
hopefully there's there's there's adults
and people teachers um for kids to reach
out to um
and to get support and it takes a
community you can't just let a kid deal
with it it's like we need the parents
the adults to come in and in this case
in the show you know we're playing these
characters that are trying to give
give tools to to the next generation as
they're working out their own stuff um
and uh you know for better for worse uh
you know these kids are
finding themselves in working through
the maze as as johnny and daniel are
doing that forging ahead and and that
this and that that happens throughout
the show to land into a positive note um
and that's hopefully where we're all
headed that's what that's where the
show's headed and yeah i think it's cool
that brings kids around along with that
so many kids are watching the show
so many messages of kids just going man
i'm i'm joining karate now and you know
and you know i was you know i'm feeling
confident young girls you know like 14
years old this you know i was bullied in
school and now i'm in karate like if we
just could get you into the dojo and
learn to bow and have respect and learn
how to be you know have some self self
confidence and all that and walk tall
and have have friends in a team you know
like i think those are subliminal things
that are happening through the show
those are messages that are coming
through and then we have this amazing
cast of these young kids that are just
electric
and then you put the heart and the fun
and the nostalgia the music and uh and
then throwing it all valley tournament
and uh you got copra kai you know
oh my gosh i love that the power of this
show thank you so much to both of you
thank you for everything you do really
no mercy thank you
and your light's perfect
you